because
i don't think the left nor the right has
figured out a way to to
solve crony capitalism and i i think
it's happening on both sides so
since you're the chief economist and
former economic hitman how would you fix
crony capitalism today or is it
are we in too deep that we can't fix it
no i never think we're in too deep
i you can't believe that uh i i think
crony capitalism is a reflection
of that guy sitting over your your left
shoulder there with the glasses on and
the red necktie
it's interesting he's wearing a red
necktie what do you think that
symbolizes
just kidding it's the same reason why
this guy's wearing a blue necktie yeah
blue tie i is the fact that this guy's
just saying i'm not wearing any color
the leader that's this is the guy i'm
curious about
yeah so milton friedman over there over
your left shoulder
you know this has been growing for a
long time but when he won the nobel
prize in 1976
you know the probably the most important
statement he made and i'm paraphrasing
here is the only responsibility of
business is to maximize
short-term profits regardless of the
social environmental costs
and that really created crony capitalism
if you want to go there because what it
does is it tells every ceo
that they have it tells every ceo that
you've not only got the right but you've
got the mandate to do whatever
it takes to maximize short-term profits
including including buying politicians
which now is done legally
because they passed the laws to make it
legal but it's still what you're calling
crony capitalism
including forming monopolies monopsonies
and and including destroying the very
resources upon which your business
depends in the long term
the idea of maximizing short term
anything is contrary to most life as we
know it on this planet
i think you're i think in slang terms
they would say john perkins you're
reaching right now
yes you're you're out of pocket is what
they would say okay
but the proper the who
the term that may be making sense it's a
little bit of spinning going on there
the guy
said the number one job meaning like the
interpretation was
your job is to make profit you're not
you are not forced to it's like saying
hey you better give 10 to church no no
i'm gonna choose to give 10 percent to
church you can't force me to give 10
to church i'm gonna give to charity you
can't force me to get you can force me
to pay taxes
which is what a lot of politicians do
but you can't force me to
get my profits i got to make sure i stay
in business so i understand that part
i don't think he was saying go buy
politicians that's not what he was
saying
but that's maybe that's not what he was
saying but that's how it was interesting
that's so this is this is almost like
biblical studies
and and we're reading one scripture from
galatians 1 6
and your interpretation is one thing and
my interpretation is another thing and
the viewers have to decide for
themselves
[Music]
you